You have to ask yourself inside the company,...
..."Where do you allow for crazy ideas?"
For real true risk to take place,...
...risk that will mostly all fail.
If Edison had hundreds of failures on his way to creating the elements inside a light bulb,...
...that's another way to think about it.
Magellan or Columbus,...
...can you imagine today Magellan, you know, receiving any money from the venture capitalists?
You know, just telling that, "I don't have a map, I don't know where I'm heading for,"...
..."I just believe you know, I can bring a lot of, you know, a gold or spices from this trip."
We don't want this risk yet.
We just believe that, you know, okay, fine.
We have so much walls around us.
Why should we take any risk ? And it's kind of a complacency.
So much was invented before, we can just benefit from using these.
Only an ability and willingness, an appetite to take risks can secure future rewards.